that's why truth and transparency is one
of the most important things in my
opinion to fixing civilization I don't
think many people are truly honest and
transparent and there's been this call
to you have to
subscribe to these certain set of values
and they can never change right it's
like if you have to be consistent
throughout a decade and if you change
your opinion that's a bad thing and I
think if you still have the same opinion
even a year from now on all things
you're not growing as an individual I'm
actually finished totally different yeah
I'm finished I'm finished my character
growth
my character's built I've worked out all
the virtues so I can't I'm like a mod or
something you can open up your XP cap
but no this is something that's that
I've experienced uh all joking aside
I've changed my positions over the years
you know I started my YouTube channel
when I was 19. I'm 28 now I hope most
people don't have the exact same
opinions between the time they're 19 and